oh
i don't feel awake enough to do this
good
high energy 203 incoming
[Music]
i'm assuming this is your episode it is
that's true because i don't remember
making these slides
it is possible that happened do you
remember seeing them
i do remember seeing them we've done
this before we certainly have second
time round i'm going to try and act as
you know stupid as i did in the first
episode we knowing you that your memory
is basically completely defunct at this
point absolutely like this will be a
whole new experience all over again yep
yeah making new flipping forward today
some
um
we did a video
now it feels like eons ago about color
spaces yes absolutely someone in the
comments said it was the least wrong
video on color space and i'm like you
know what that's the bar i'm gonna
strive for today as well okay we're not
going to manage because there's more
there's more on color spaces that i want
to talk about but if you haven't seen it
if you you haven't seen it you should go
back i mean i saw it i don't know i was
there did you see it or did you just
record it
this was proof that it was in the room
it is i nodded along you see did you pay
attention who knows well let's find out
let's find out so color spaces we talked
about this again if you don't know what
this diagram means
uh it's all in the previous video srgb
in the the smaller one smaller triangle
yes p3 yeah
rec 2020 that is correct and the well
done have a cookie after we're done
thank you um so the the curvy bit is a a
representation of the xyz color space
which and inside this this colored bit
those are all the colors a human can see
yes and so these triangles form a subset
of
these colors that humans can see and the
whole xyz space was modeled through
humans
matching colors so basically it tells
you
uh what happens when two colored lights
mix how do we as humans perceive that i
love i love these graphs like this
because they're kind of a joke because
outside the biggest triangle there is a
load of colors that screens can't
represent which people are viewing this
on a screen
yes so they're colored in bits are
a lie yeah yeah they're kind of roughly
that those are green colors different
green colors but green and the blue
colors you know similar okay um
you usually see these because you know
display p3
srgb
erection 20 are about display device
capabilities and as you may know we have
little pixels in red green and blue
which emit light and then the slight
mixes inside our eye almost and we
perceive a color so these
rectangle these triangles represent
which colors these devices can actually
create by mixing the pixels and which
colors they cannot
yes and people at home uh
probably watching this uh on
oh
i mean one of the two inner triangles
i'd say like it's less common to have a
computer display which is right 2020 but
even then our video will most likely
just prescribe srgb anyway
yes so that's another layer of confusion
that you know if just because your
monitor can display a rect 20 doesn't
mean it will because if the media that
is input into the device says hey i'm
using srgb
yes yes we're an srgb series https rgb
that exactly cool that's the s and https
[Laughter]
so these three color spaces as you said
srgb p3 and r20 are actually available
in css now yes so so far by default
everything in css everything on the web
pretty much was srgb but it turns out
you know people who like colors
want access to the other colors that are
outside of the srgb triangle
and so now
we have this syntax to do that which is
already kinda exciting that we have more
colors so all these these color spaces
are about giving you access to more
colors and uh safari actually has
support for this like in safaritp you
can use these syntax and actually have
this cool color picker thing where you
actually see whether the fancy color
you're selecting is inside or outside
the srgb gamut oh that's nice so you
know you can see we actually don't get
many new blues but some new reds and a
lot more
uh greens you get when way more greens
look at that yeah whoa so much green
incredible and it kind of matches with
the triangles we saw earlier um so
there's going to be a lot of safari in
this episode because it's
it will be implemented in chrome but
it's not even in canary yet so yeah it's
credit to them for
trailblazing that's great absolutely
great when you say not equivalent what
does that mean so you know i
turned
the first color srgb one zero zero is as
right as possible in srgb yes we have
just seen that what that you know this
p3 has more red so full red and display
p3 is a different red than the red and
srgb yes um i could have put the
equivalent number in there but that
would have been work that i didn't want
to have to do xyz is the one which is
all possible colors and more and so if
you put a two in there what happens does
the red come out the monitor and just
there's so much too much red to even
contain within the screen even xyz one
zero zero is a color that doesn't exist
brilliant so that and that is actually
we'll talk about that what does a
browser do when you give it a color that
it can't display or that potentially
doesn't even exist full crash yeah just
like panic delete itself
yeah
otherwise it would break the universe
yes backwards compatible right
absolutely exactly
so as i said like we have these color
spaces which are about giving you access
to more colors but it's all just a
subset of x y z there is also
different perspectives onto x y z
um
most notably l a b and l c h and we're
going to talk about these now a little
bit to explain how they're different
so some of these are available in in
chrome right well so does the
um
there's the other one that's not rgb
that we use which begins with an h uh
hsl hsl so is that one of these
perspectives hsl no yeah no h no yes no
no that's great
brilliant explanation just moving
australian and then added another
no it's um hsl is just a different
perspective onto srgb
so it is in this has the same
constraints
um like you don't get access to more
color by using hsl but it is the same
switch of perspective
like that you go from a
a cartesian coordinate system where each
acts as a color to something that has an
angle and stuff which you do with with
hsl right exactly and this will actually
happen here so lab and lch are
interesting because they are
perceptually uniform great keyword so
all of these are
you don't need me you're just
congratulating yourself well done sermon
great keyword okay well the thing is i
see it thrown around so much and it
actually
it seems self-explanatory to people who
already know what it means but if you
don't know what it means
it's not self-explanatory i don't know
what it means so i'll explain it to you
thank you so all of these color spaces
all of the xyz stuff is perceptual
because it is based on humans perceiving
colors and modeling
a space around how humans perceive it
like you match colors and like oh this
is how i pre this is orange i perceive
it as orange and that's how xyz was made
but it's not perceptually uniform
which means that
you know you have one color and you add
a bit of red to it
and then you bet the same amount of red
to it afterwards that doesn't mean you
will see it as a linear increment of
redness in the color like the uniformity
isn't there
that like it could actually turn a
completely different color technically
um
but it's like xyz and all the subspaces
are about how light mixes and how humans
perceive that mixed light right so the
idea if you double the amount of red you
as a human would look at it and go
that looks like twice as much red even
if it might not be no yeah no that's
actually not the case with xyz so
because yes but with these ones
yeah with the lib
uniform space that is the case
especially around lightness where you go
hey i want to double the lightness you
double the number and you get twice as
bright a color which is obviously very
important for
you know intuition around colors and
when you pick your palettes and stuff
um so let's start with lab
this is
the srgb gamut inside lab so every
colorized pixel in this graph
is a color that is inside rgb srgb every
pixel is outside of these is technically
still a color but at least not inside
srgb okay just like x y z there's also
coordinates that aren't even real colors
so that can be a bit confusing you can
actually come with coordinates that
don't represent any real color in the
real world and it's just
pointless in a way
um so lab has three coordinates l a and
b hence the name l is for lightness is
between
zero and 100 and as i said such uniform
so if you go from 100 to 50 it's half a
sprite because it's half the brightness
value which is quite nice
a is the red green axis
b is the yellow blue axis
it's not very intuitive i'm okay i'm not
gonna lie but it is
one of the first perception uniform
color spaces um so here for example you
know we're getting a 40 brightness on a
we're going to minus 50 as a is the red
green axis this is a nice green tone as
rendered here
uh
by safari nice so but again i feel like
this is not necessarily very intuitive
to use um but as a rule of thumb
both the ax and the b axis go from
uh
i think minus 130 to plus 130 to cover
the human gamut right okay so yeah then
again covering the human gamut doesn't
mean that your screen can actually
create that color with their pixels so
while you might have a real color it
doesn't mean that it's actually a useful
color on the web because
i guess i'm laughing at it being 130
it's like why is it that but a magic
number out of a hat yeah but we're used
to using like two five five like for
which you know if you were showing if
you show someone outside tech that's
like well where did that number come
from that's something they just made up
okay okay i'll get over that i'm not
sure where this comes from i think it's
just it's just a number just deal with
it all right i'm dealing with it so
let's talk about lch
so lch is the hsl of xyz
i want i want to
see this in the museum is there a museum
where there's this rocky that's like a
nice sculpture
was is this how it was invented did
someone dig up that rock almost like
spaces i found the color stone
and it's in this glass thing rotating
around so i will say i don't find this
visualization very helpful wikipedia but
i had to put something on the slide okay
yeah it's very pretty though
so lch is the same thing as hsl in that
it has an angle and the lightness and
the third axis here is chromaticity
it's more intuitive because you know we
we kind of get used to like zero degrees
it's red and 120 degrees is green from
hsl yes those kind of things we kind of
know is it the same here it's exactly
the same the only thing that's weird is
that you the value you can use for c
as you can see here depends on both
other values like at zero you're
obviously black at 100 you're light but
in the middle like you can sometimes go
with chromosomes 230 sometimes you can
go only to 20. and again it is quite
easy to fall outside the gamut which
with
lch
but it is a bit more intuitive okay to
use
so again we can just 50 percent
lightness 80 chromaticity zero degrees
is a nice vibrant red a bit pinker here
because chromaticity is again can't
change actually what we usually perceive
as hue because of human eyes and when
you're saying like you can fall outside
the gamut that's that would be the srgb
gamut right like yes well you can even
fall outside the p3 gamut or
physical real world color gamut amazing
all of that is possible and it's
actually a good question like what
happens
if we give something that is outside the
gamut and we'll talk about that a bit oh
i was going to try and guess well the
first thing that's already weird is that
there's actually a thing in the spec
that i think is quite stupid because if
i were to instead of 50 lightness here
say zero percent lightness what would
you expect
i mean
i would expect it to be black and you're
gonna write this right it should be
black currently safari does this it
gives you a dark red no why
stupid okay actually let me explain to
you
why it is okay but also give you hope in
that the css working group ages this is
stupid and they want to change it all
right all right but i mentioned in the
last video that
x y z is the the common denominator that
one that we use for conversion from one
color space another instead of like you
know going straight from color space a
okay space b every conversion goes via x
y z it's like the source of truth color
space to convert between all the color
space that are out there
and that's exactly what safari is doing
so we you know we define lch with or we
give a color defined with zero lightness
80 chromaticity in zero hue
and then i just look up the formula for
how do i convert from lch to xyz
and that's just straight up math this is
what comes out the other side okay and
then i look at math how do i go from x y
z to s rgb
and that's what comes out no and there's
a negative number which we know srgb
doesn't do and so how
safari currently handles that because
how you should handle it is unspecced
effectively it clamps it looks every
component and says hey you're outside go
between zero and one
and so that turns into
a darker shred right whereas i guess a
proper operation would be to shift by
you know some amount which would end up
with
zero it's actually quite hard to figure
out how to describe what you should do
but leo varu and chris lee have
actually a really good website called
css.land slash
picker
lch we'll see a link in the description
we'll put a link in the description and
you can see like once you go to lights
100 every color is white if you go to
lightness zero everything is black and
they have um dark up an algorithm that
handles this correctly and this is most
likely what is going to be added to the
css color spec so that
we don't get a dark red when we just
specify zero percent lightness good
thank you leo and chris that will
probably be changed and fixed soon
um what's also quite nice actually i
found that in the css color for spec
there is actually a reference
implementation of all these color
conversions and very readable in simple
javascript it is mostly supposed to be
red but it does work if you want to
programmatically red as in hang on
that's an overloaded term in this video
it's mostly supposed to be viewed with
your eyes with your eyes consumed as
text
okay
um
it's very clearly written so you really
see how do you do all these conversions
how do you define the colors luminance
and if you want to use
if you want to do color operations
programmatically lea also maintains
color.js which is a library that has all
of these things baked in with more
performance and actually a nicer api so
that's something worth looking at i i'm
really happy that they've done this
because i
i've been reading some compositing specs
and stuff and it's written in maths
which i don't understand i don't
understand the symbols i find it
hard to deal with like these one letter
values and stuff here's a big sigma
right yeah it's like thanks i'll i'll
take it no but and then being able to
you know just find well that's what i've
been doing with this compositing stuff
is going to finding a implementation
written in c or as a shader or something
that's like oh now i can we know code we
can recode don't do the math give me the
code exactly so this this is great and
also very well commented so definitely
worth a look let's talk a bit about how
to mix colors because we've been talking
about mixing light
um but css actually doesn't do that as
of now because let's say we have you
know we have red and blue
what is the color in the middle
right what one yeah so one two seven of
each right like exactly so that's
basically you you look at each
component like r is one component the r
value the green value and the blueprint
each called components and you just
you have them like you what's in the
middle between 0 and 255 and you do it
per component and the same you do if you
want to do like a 75 25 weighting so you
could do you know 192 and 64 and the
same the other way around
and this is how
color mixing works in cs and it's
actually also how gradients work in css
right so and now you can tell that
actually when you do just per component
the color space in which you define a
color has a huge influence
on what the output of mixing is because
you know in rgb it's r g and b but in
hsl it is
h s and l that are now being looked at
independently and a different color will
come out of the mixing process depending
on
in which color space you want to mix
and that is something they are now
adding to css where you can say
explicitly i want to mix these two
colors i want to mix them in a certain
way and the mixing should happen in this
specific color space
so basically this says mix these colors
in srgb which is the default anyway yes
which is the one we just saw before but
you can basically define you know i mean
dislike p3 doesn't make sense because
it's effectively just a subs of xyz but
you could put lab or lch or something in
there
define your colors in one space and mix
them in another so so that's the when
you're saying sligb the
the values it takes are not just like
the gamuts it's also the the
perspectives on those gametes
exactly can you do both because you can
use can you say
well i guess there's no real such thing
as as lab in
srgb is there it's well you can you can
basically define your colors
the way you define the color is
completely independent or for your mix
instead of just writing red i could
write color display p3 or or lab or lch
i see so you define the color in one
color space and then for the mixing css
will convert however necessary to do the
mixing appropriately so in
the last episode you identified how
gradients were hold on to that all right
i'm holding on so color mix is
the result of the color mix function is
a single color which you know is good
that's handy
um
for gradients we don't have a syntax yet
they are thinking about adding something
like this and an additional syntax where
you now also say i want the gradients to
be mixed in a specific color space
brilliant hasn't been specked yet so for
the purposes of this demos i've just
been creating 255 divs next to each
other and assigning a new color to each
so we can talk about
how this color mixing really affects
gradients and the color mixing process
so you might remember this from last
time i'm mixing red and green
and as you can see
the the color space i choose is quite
important we talked about last time you
know in s rgb you dip to this darkish
yellow
blurby color that's actually not really
nice so you mentioned last time that the
doing things in linear color is the is
that x y z basically x y z which is c um
and you can see like it looks nicer but
actually you go away from red really
really quickly yes lab
very even very nice
uh and lch almost the same i personally
actually like hsl the most even though
it's neither uniform brightness nor is
it
it it's just you you rotate the hue but
actually i think in turn looking at this
i like it the best what i really like
about
this syntax is
yeah if you go to an article about um
linear gradients in css one of the
examples that we'll come up with is
a rainbow yeah right and the way they'll
do it is by having like a load of points
yeah but i think you're saying here is
that you would be able to do this with
two points yeah you go from zero three
sixty you go from zero to 360 and
it would go all the way around the color
wheel and keep everything covered and
that's actually really really nice right
that's that is really really nice um so
yeah this is the the red green
comparison where i think you know
there's some differences but overall it
looks
fairly similar like not a huge
difference if we look at red and blue it
gets a
bit more different again i actually feel
like hsl
looks the best although lch also looks
quite nice
um i think it will depend on what your
i'm about to say something obvious yeah
it depends on the visual effects you're
going for but i think it's interesting
because i as far as i know most design
tools don't allow you to choose yet
which color space you want your gradient
in but it it will become
a design choice because i don't think
there's a clear winner it it really
depends on your use case which color
space interpolation looks best for what
you're going for yes i think we can all
agree that the srgb one is not very good
no but but the rest is is kind of like
world well now hold on because we've
just been mixing primary colors like
pure red and pure blue pure red and blue
poop who wrote poop we've only been
mixing mate if you have blue poo
that's an issue you're a smurf
we've only been mixing primary colors so
pure red pure blue or pure red and pure
green um let's mix
non-primary colors because things will
get wild how about
yellow and blue wait hang on these are
very different these are very different
so i think we can still agree mixing
srgb looks sad yeah xyz
technically uniform brightness across
but not necessarily what i was going for
i think if i imagine going from yellow
to blue i wouldn't expect an almost
white in the middle um all of these are
wrong i don't like any of them right led
it's e l c h and h is l again not good
it's kind of weird purple in the middle
that i wouldn't expect okay that's a
that's a different statement i like lch
and hsl they're not what i expected but
they're pretty they yes that is they're
colorful they trip
um yeah so it's it's like there's i
don't even know
which one i prefer here but again i
think that's the same advice applies at
the point what are you doing what are
you trying to achieve in your design
yeah um
so i think it's just really interesting
that for me it kind of
it kind of became clear that for
gradients
the color space in which you interpolate
is part of the design choice and
something that needs to be shared with
the developer that implements the
gradients
because you know it will look wildly
differently otherwise yes
adam's favorite is doing blue to white
or blue to black because if you look at
srgb it's really hard to unsee once you
need it it actually dips to a bit of
purple
yes it does along the gradient and you
usually don't want that
when you go from
black to blue and so his his method of
fixing srgb is like to add as you said
like an additional stop that counteracts
the the purple shift um i mean lch and
hsl just go full purple on you yes so
like again like you can see like it all
looks different and people just need to
start working with these gradients in a
bit differently it's really interesting
to see yeah so the the reason that sigb
is
not great in any of these examples is
because yes it's like all of them
linearly interpolating
but the values in srgb are not actually
linear no they have this gamma
correction on top which stems from crt
monitors but it's coincidentally also
kind of how our eyes adapt to brightness
so it's like it's it's a it's a happy
coincidence but it it doesn't work for
color mixing yes and stuff so most of
the time when you operate on colors you
kind of need to remove the gamma
correction and that's called linear srgb
or
xyz which is actually in this sense then
in this scenario
fulfills the same purpose all right one
last thing i want to talk about
did you notice that hsl has a different
text color than all the others
i do notice it yes do you know why
because it would be hard to read
otherwise it would be hard to write why
okay good and you know who made the
color black
it's you
no no css chose the text color what
because that's a new thing now
um there's a new function called color
contrast
which you put in a color as a first
argument and then you say versus and
then you give a list of colors and color
contrast will choose the color which has
the highest contrast to the first color
fully automatically which especially you
know in the context of dark mode or
color animations can be huge it actually
has an additional um syntax where you
can specifically define the wacag
contrast ratio oh that's and it will
pick the first color in the list that
qualifies so you can actually express
preference you can express them in the
order of preference is there a way to
tell it to just figure out from the
background
no okay because i think that's quite
hard because you know it there's
compositing and transparency so it's
actually quite hard to figure out a bit
of a round trip
at least yeah okay yeah yeah and then
also it ends up being you know per pixel
because if you have a background image
like yeah yes it would have to be an
average across the element so okay okay
fine i would rather have this and
nothing at all at least oh right i'm not
criticizing this i was just i don't know
looking for ideas
the next thing to work on here is um
it is implement safari and you can see
like when it comes to green it switches
attacks to black because humans perceive
the brightness of green much more than
the other colors and i think that's
going to be great like with a lot more
color
construction going on this will be super
handy and speaking of that
there used to be a proposal for this
color syntax where you you take a color
and you have modifier function to make a
color lighter like the stuff that's in
sass and everything like that okay this
is not gonna happen
great in the syntax there's another
syntax but this all right there's still
tutorials out there talking about this
everybody should know this is not the
syntax that is
has been removed from the spec this is
not happening anymore instead they
actually opted for something more
powerful because it turns out you know
lightness or contrast is not easily
talked about if you don't know in which
color space you're working okay so what
they're doing instead i think this is a
really nice work around they actually
allow you to define a color and say i
want to work in hsl so use the color
from this variable
in hsl and then you get h s and l as
variables that you can use in calc
expressions
to do your stuff and so whatever you
choose whether it's hsl lab rgb
you will get these variables to do
proper math on with your calc expression
so example if you're in lab you can
literally just say okay add 20 lightness
to my color and the color that comes out
will be 20 lighter
which i actually think is quite
expressive and is that fine even if the
input color is not expressed in hsl
convergence if not use the hsl function
but the primary color variable here
points to something that is defined in
p3 or lab
the browser will do the conversion give
you the variable values probably the
clamping if necessary um
and you can do math and that will allow
you to do stuff like define some primary
colors and everything else could be
computationally generated both the color
contrast for the text colors but also
lighter shades darker shades like at
some point i do envision that we will
actually just you know define some
primary colors for dark wood and light
and the rest is programmatically derived
very nice from those colors which sounds
like a great kind of future to me yeah
um
yeah so if you want to know more this
was like a speedrun of what is in css
color four and five most of it is in
safari coming to chrome hopefully
in q1 2022. all right all right
um
i'm looking forward to it i am too
so what you want what do you want to
you know
yeah i mean come on
say your words and then